senator Cory Gardner of Colorado is also
on Capitol Hill he's part of the
Republicans Senate leadership and is a
member of the Senate Budget Committee
senator good morning it's good to have
you let me pick up where Nancy left off
Senator McConnell has said it's been
difficult to know where the president is
Senator Graham has said the same thing
there was a time when Congress would
just put a bill on the floor and let the
president sign it or not sign it why
isn't Congress doing that well I think
we still have time to negotiate look I'm
part of a bipartisan working group this
group of six that has put a bill
together to solve this daca challenge
but we have time I think it's
irresponsible to shut the government
down when we still have time to work
we're still communicating we still have
opportunities to solve this problem what
Washington doesn't need to do is pick up
at sticks and go to its collective
partisan corners the shutdown politics
that we're seeing today are simply
ridiculous and who's going to get the
blame well how about a bunch of
Washington bozos that can't seem to get
their job done well it but one of the
things that the argue those arguing for
using the shutdown as leverage is with a
president who's changing his opinion a
lot the only way you can get the bozos
in line is if you attach it to something
vital like this and nothing focuses the
mind like a hanging yeah I'm old enough
to remember back when Chuck Schumer was
demanding a clean continuing resolution
during the Obama administration to keep
the government open comparing holding
the government hostage to immigration
politics was simply creating
governmental chaos and so to turn around
four years later and reject a clean CR
something they completely absolutely
agree with to reject six-year funding of
chip this is the longest term of funding
reauthorization that women and
children's health care has ever received
to reject that because of this hostage
taking I think is irresponsible look we
have time to get our work done I want to
see this done sooner rather than later I
think it is absolutely critical that we
act as soon as possible but to solve
these problems you don't do it by simply
throwing a temper tantrum and shutting
the government down that's irresponsible
what about the Democrats idea of a
short-term fun spending bill just so we
you all can continue to work out the
details on daca why is that not an
acceptable option well the irony is
Chuck Schumer went to the floor last
night complained about bad policies of a
continuing resolution and his solution
is an even shorter term continuing
second verse same as the first this is
kind of the policies that Washington
gets stuck in look if Congress had a
yelp rating I'm pretty sure it'd be
pretty low well meantime the clock is
ticking senator so what's your
prediction I hope that the adults in the
room will come together and say look
we're going to continue finding a
solution for children who came to this
country through no fault of their own we
have a responsibility and an obligation
to do that and I believe there's near
unanimity in Congress to find that
solution and I hope that by midnight
people will realize that shut down
politics it's not a smart way to govern
senator do you know any dreamers oh
absolutely look I live in a town that is
filled with people who came to this
country many first-generation Americans
our daughter 14 years old has many
classmates who the only country they
have ever known is America yet they came
here at a very young age through no
fault of their own we have to find this
solution this is hurting our communities
by not finding the solution but it would
also hurt our communities our men and
women in uniform though you just did a
story on the flu epidemic what happens
to CDC efforts in this massive flu
outbreak if the government is shut down
look this is something that we have to
address but let's do it responsibly
without hurting so many other Americans
in a collateral damage kind of way
well not going to call you bozos but you
do both of you both sides say they want
the same thing you sound like squabbling
siblings where your moms at the driver's
seat saying look knock it off just work
this out that's exactly right that's
what it has to happen that's exactly
what has to happen all right all right
senator Gardner can't wait to see how
this story turns out thank you very much
thank you